今日はこちらしていく勘弁ですあの今日はですねええ
テーマが2つあります一つは先ほど中国語で行ったテーマであります
あの input すなわち日本流で言うと
多読多聴の言葉の勉強方法の
利点どうしてそれが今いわゆる電動的な
その
元号講座
よりも効果的だというテーマとそれと同時にですね
うーん
yes いい感じですジャブ鯉時々出てきます
a もしねえええ
みなさんまた木のビリを見ている日本人あるいは日本語のできる皆さんがですね
私と話をしたいならばその後きますゴール+のね
その
はい担うというシステムですね今使い始めているわけですよ
それは非常に便利で
私も含めてですね10人がその一つの話にさんができるわけですよ
ギャ面にそれぞれの人のビデオが出てきます
で是非
言葉の勉強あるいはもっと具体的に
リンクの使い方について質問があればぜひ
こういう歯が音に参加してください横暴者があれば
ぐごーグーグルプラスのリンク
iring 9リンクの pa ですね
私に言ってください参加したいと
名前とそしてやはり宮軍フラッシュのまたアカウントも一応ですけれども
あの家
あの youtube なんか部分の関係あるから数
グー輸入チューブに何が登録するときに自動的に動く明日メンバーになるかもしれない
けどそれはちょっと具体的には私を詳しくはないです
ok メインのテーマはあの input いわゆる多読多聴
通して一番効果的一番良い言葉
の勉強の方法なのか
5つの原因がーそして欠点も一つある
で僕ちょっとこれ書きましたからね今
だんだん頭は頭が狂ってますからと美味しいとってるから
一度のメインの特徴とか利点
まず1つはですねいわゆるたんドクター筐体非常に効果的である
それ以上に大事なんですよ私直後1年勉強しました
ちぇぶわぁああ難しい言葉ですよ
それじゃあ最初の8ヶ月は
ああああああ
あのわたり多読たっ町だけだったんですよ
たくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだりそして合意を増やしていきました
リンクを使いましてねそれはあのその後
8が月のタグ多読た今日の後でですね
た遠くた長も続きながらあの着人と4回と通じて話をすること
またが増えてきたんですよ誤り言う pupa てぃそれじゃああの毎週1時間から
4もう1週間後時間話をしてそしてプラービってですね
たーっぷり切手ですねもう非常に有効にもう毎日
7時間も8時間もちぇるを話してですね非常にはたちの
中5話話するその辺の能力が非常にまあ
アップしたわけですけれどもその基礎はですね
木次番はやはり多読多聴だから効果的であることは私が何回もか
あの照明
していますだから攻撃その次はですねこれやり易いですよね
別にどこからクラスですね学校行ったりするようなひじをはないし
先生を雇うような必要もないしただはもう
けぐとよーそれからまぁ最初のうちですね
あの新しい言葉を勉強するときにえ
ちょっとつまらない者の処方者に対するあんまりの保証ぐらいその内容を読む聞く必要
があるけれども
まあできるだけ早いうちにですねそれじゃなくて
新しい面白い自分が今日自分が興味を感じるような材料を
読んだり聞いたり五社の中から
ああああ
意味のあるぐよだんだん覚えたりするとですね
やはりそれがそういう勉強方法が面白い
そして色んな事を勉強できます
チョコの例で言いますとは性質がそのだいたい3ヶ月
始まってから3ヶ月ぐろー飛来数のチェコの歴史だとか
正義だとかいろんなものについてですね聞いたり読んだりして
だからカーブに着いたときにすぐにもうそういう
やはり
プラベもいろんな奇跡の移籍とかそういうまあ歴史的な建物に対する知識がい
すでに豊富にあったわけですだから私の短い
ラベルの題字は5日間だけだったけれどもやはり非常に有効に使えました
いろんな人と話しできましたしそしてその非常に
まあ面白い
きれいな街よねいうふうにん上できました
ああそうだから友好的であるとそして便利でやりをすっと処理からまあをも広いと今度
はですね
奇遇と読むだけですと気
そういうあの味噌
割と起こしに行くだけですよ話するときによく来
ミスが起こりうるわけですよね発音がよくないんだとか
その文法が間違ってるとか
3月
ことば遣いが間違ってるとかただ聞くとですねそういう問題がない
唯えっ時々分かりませんとかね
あるいはちょっと意味がちょっと曖昧だとか
そういうことはありますけどそれは構いませんそういうことは当然あのたドクター長を
続くことによって所有ような踏め f 明確なところはだんだんと明確になってきます
それはそういうたどった今日を
すぎましてあの言葉に馴染むことになるわけですよ
慣れていく理解が増えてくる
非常に沈ん的にいろんな前は分からなかったところの
ところがだんだんとわかりやすくなります
そうだそれが一つみたい
それから最後年午後10名はねぇ
これはあのた2今日は安いです
学校行って先生にお金払うような必要ないです
図書館からあの
一応な財を借りたりインターネットでそういうのを探したり
まあ人気のメンバーであればリンクを使ったりですねそれは非常に安い
まあこういう5つの点がオムない点だと思います
効果的である安いであるやすと y やすいことであるあるとあの便利市でもできます
チークのは読むのは
アイスてみ数
ね起こさないとか
まあ面白いとか安いとかただあの
欠点は一つ
その他が来たーー長にその成功するためにはやはり勉強する人が指導権を取らないと
いけない
勉強すぐ二頭は自信を持って自信を持って
そして強い意志0
どうしてもこの方も言葉を勉強したいと
例えばをもう広い内容を自分でも探しました
そして位
1週間1回じゃなくて毎日
あのピグとかまあ読むとそういうような石そういうような独立性が非常に大事なんです
よ
それは学校ですとそれは別にないです
顎を見てばいいとそしていろんな人は学校行くですね食で
何かをましたという感じをするわけですよ私が今日は英語を勉強しました
分
どれくらい勉強しましたかいやーは知りませんけども学校行きました
だからちょいばいいとが食いましたただ実際としてはね実際その
じゃあそういういろんな学校で
勉強している状態を見るとですねこれは日本であろうが
カードであろうがですね進歩する人が少ないです
少ないです多分進歩する人が成功する等が非常に独立性の強い
1心の強い人であるわけですよ
そういう人ならば別に
高い学校じゃなくてもイッてもいいでしょ
行ってもいいですよただああ
た国単調という方法を
使えば元効果的だと思いますと同時にやはり学校僕は別に各艦艇じゃないんだけれども
学校いっても言ってもやはり
た道た長が命あるべき私が例えば中国語を勉強した時に毎日学校へ通うしたんですよ
だけどもメインのお渡し
議論一番をその時間を使った
その
活動勉強方法はやはり多読た巨
そういうわけなんですよそしてあの私と標本そういうはの
宮クラスと葉がを会議で私と質問したりして
したいならば是非
9 u 9 u 私の youtube 茶のでもあるいは
へ
リンクのグーグルプラスのページで r
を教えてくださいじゃどうもありがと
ます